Hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for:
The Transforming Ninja Star!
Similar to the eight-pointed ninja star this is an all new four pointed one that I designed
together with Jeremy Shafer. You can check out his tutorial by clicking on this link up here
It also changes from a frisbee into
a ninja star with two simple moves
Making it requires four square sheets of
any size I'm going to be using two
different color printer sheets that I
will split into quarters but if you want
to use one sheet or you can even try to
make a super one by using the whole
printer sheet it's totally up to you. So
once you have the paper ,let's get
started. If you'd like to have two
different colors in your star like mine,
we'll need to split two different sheets.
Once we have the four squares we can
turn each into these modular units which
are all identical. Once we finish making
four we can then interlock them to
finish the star. Take both sheets and
fold them in half lengthwise making a
nice sharp crease down the edge. We can
then split them by tearing them or
cutting them. Set the other two pieces
aside. Fold both shorter outer sides onto
the longer side and once again cut or
tear along the edges. This makes four
squares measuring 4.25 inches if you're
using letter size paper. Now that we have the four squares we can
go on to make the modular units. Remember, they're all made the exact same way so
I'll go through with you how to make one
of them and then you can make the others
on your own. Grab one of the sheets and
let's get started since we now have a
crease in the paper going diagonally
this way we're gonna make one going this
way by taking the upper left corner and
folding it down to the bottom right
corner. Once the corners are lined up,
just make a nice sharp crease on the
upper left here all throughout the paper
with your fingernail
because sharp creases will make it a lot
easier to make the modules. You can open
up the paper again and you'll see we now
have an X in it. We're going to take the
top and fold it down to the bottom once
again lining up the edges as neatly as
you can and making a nice sharp crease
on the top now. When you open up the
paper, just hold the edges so that
they're facing downwards and all the
folds are Mountain folds-- as you'll see
we have a little upside-down V or
mountain in the paper. Then we can take
the two top corners and we're going to
airplane fold them directly into the
middle like this so that the top edge
lies on the midline and the corner is on
the center point. Line it up as neatly as
possible and then we can make a
crease on the outside. Do the same with
the upper left corner: just fold it
directly next to the other one trying to
be as neat as possible, and make another
sharp crease. Now we could take the
outside edge here and
fold it directly onto this diagonal
crease. Fold it like this just round it
off so that the tip here lines up on
this point and the edge on the diagonal.
Now we're going to crease the edge here
from this horizontal crease all the way
down so just press right here and just
crease it like that making sure that
it's lined up then we can just run our
fingernail against the outside edge. Now
we can open it up and do the same with
the left side: take the edge round it off,
line it up like that and we're going to
crease it from this horizontal crease
right here all the way down the paper
Once again, just run your fingernail
against it. Then you can open it up now
you'll see we folded these little
triangles and they've gotten folded back
We're just gonna pick up the corner here
and we're gonna tuck this triangle or
tip right on the inside by folding it
down and then flattening it back out. So
just tug the corner, fold downwards on
the triangle here and fold it back down.
Then we could flatten it once again so
we should have something that looks like
this. I'm going to take these two edges
and we're going to push them together
like this and we're just gonna pinch the
top point. We're going to take this edge
and we're going to push upwards on it
like this and if you made that crease so
that it's a mountain fold it should kind
of get pointed upwards like that like a
little triangle. Just take it lift it up
and then we could take these two edges
and flatten them together like this. Then,
we could just flatten the paper once
again. Now you'll see we have this
triangle that's on top and we're just
going to take the point of the triangle
and fold it right onto this
little corner here just rounding it off
and meeting it up with that point on
this crease here. Once it's lined up like
that then we could just make a nice
sharp crease on the top. Now we can
unfold it and we're just going to open
up these two edges here
holding it like this and just spreading
it open like that. You'll see we have
this big triangle and the little
triangle: We're gonna press on the big
triangle so that this big triangle
that's all the way on top is going
downward. So we're gonna invert it or
reverse fold it by pressing downwards on
this edge like this just like that and
just press downwards and then we could
squeeze the two edges together like this
Now you'll see we have this little
triangle on the bottom we're just gonna
flip it over and we're gonna do the same
thing. Open up the two edges hold it like
this and just press on this edge so that
the triangle gets inverted or reverse
folded by pressing downwards on the top.
Push down and flatten it out so you
should have a piece of paper that looks
just like this and you finished the
first module. We're just going to make
three more of these and then we could
join them together.
Now that we've
completed the four modules, we can
interlock them together in order to
finish the transforming ninja star. Each
module has a point and also two tips or
flaps which will lock into the back of
the next piece and slide in a groove or
track just like that. We're going to hold
two pieces so that the point is on the
left side and the flaps are on the right
side. Remember, the flaps are where we tucked in those
little triangles into the center on the
right side. You'll notice that right next
to the point here you should have a
little crease that I've marked here on
the paper. We're going to be using
that as a guide. We can turn the piece
on the right 90 degrees like this and
we're going to place it in between the two
flaps here all the way against the base
of that triangle until it doesn't go
anymore. Now to make sure that they're
perpendicular all we need to do is just
slide it up until the bottom of these
flaps here align with that little crease.
We could just hold it there like
this. We're going to fold this top flap
away and the back flap
towards us so that we can slide it in
between here. Just hold this flap back
and we can fold this one down like
this let go the back one and fold it
towards us. Give it a little pinch, and
then you could unfold it. Then all we
need to do is to just slide it right in
between the groove here just like this
and the back one will go next to it like
that. Then you can close it and give
it a little pinch. Then what we need to
do is just slide it back and forth and
break it in a little bit. Now that
we've done that we can move on to the
next one. In my case I have blue, red...
I'm going to take a blue one and do the
same thing. Slide the one on the right in
between the two flaps and align the
bottom of it here with that little
crease. Then hold it, take the back one
fold it away and crease that little tip
over let go the back one and take the
back tip and fold it towards me just
give it a little pinch
unfold them and tuck them into that
little groove on this side and the back
one goes on the other side. Give it a
little pinch and once again just break
it in a little bit. Now all we need to do
is the last one. Take the last one and do
the same exact thing. If they start to
get a little bent it's okay, we're just
joining this one now. So just put it in
here, seat it all the way and place it on
that crease. Take the back flap hold it
back fold this over let go hold this one
towards you. Give it a little pinch
unfold them and then tuck them into that
groove. Give it a pinch and we can once
again break it in a little bit.
Now you'll notice in the middle here there's a little piece that the flaps can
sometimes go over like that even though
it's supposed to kind of stay on the
side. That's okay as long as you just
kind of break it in and it finds its own
little path. Now for the last one we're
just going to slide the first one in
between the two flaps of the last when we just joined just like that and once
again make sure that they're
perpendicular and do the same exact
thing. Hold the back one fold this over
and fold this one towards you. Then all
we need to do is just tuck it in like this
by opening it up and tucking it
in there. Same thing with this one tuck
it in there and give it a pinch. Then
all we need to do is just break it in a
little bit so if it pops out that's okay
Just slide it back and forth like
that take the two opposite ones and just
kind of push it back and forth do the
same thing this way and then to
transform it you just take the two
opposite points push them together like
this turn it clockwise 90 degrees take
the two ends and push it like that.
Then to open it you just pull it let's
pull it here and pull it here and there
you go there's your Transforming Ninja
Star! In the untransformed state it flies
just like a frisbee so I put my finger
right here on the tip here and I flick
my wrist out holding it pretty much
horizontal.
Let's try the super one!
Oh, right in my face!
In the transformed configuration you could do it the same way just put your finger
on the end here and flick it like a
frisbee. Or you can also throw it
vertically like this
Thank you guys so much for watching my
tutorial for the transforming ninja star
if you did enjoy it please give it a
thumbs up down below and also if you're
not already subscribed Click the
SUBSCRIBE and notification bell. Let me
know what you guys thought of it down
below. I just like to thank all of my
subscribers especially the ones who have
been following me for so many years you
guys leave awesome comments especially
on the last video the paper popper video
There were some really cool comments
from people who have been watching they
said for over 10 years which is pretty
crazy it makes my day a lot of time so
definitely leave me a comment down below
and I will try to reply to it whenever I
get the chance thanks for watching and
I'll see you soon